turning back to the pandemic there's a
lot of concern about vaccine
misinformation on platforms like
facebook and president biden has pushed
social media companies to take stronger
action to block it nearly all of the
latest covet deaths are among
unvaccinated people in a one-on-one
interview we spoke exclusively with
facebook ceo and co-founder that's mark
zuckerberg we asked him how many people
have seen false information about covet
and vaccines on his platform
i get that you all have taken down 18
million pieces of misinformation but one
of the things that the white house has
asked for repeatedly and still hasn't
gotten a number
is how much misinformation have people
viewed and shared do you have that
number
well
if we see harmful misinformation on the
platform then we take it down it's
against our policies so the 18 million
number that i shared is the number of
pieces of content that um that we've
seen on the platform that
that we take down now do we catch
everything you know of course there are
mistakes that we make or areas where we
need to improve but but that's the
that's the best number that we have in
terms of what we've seen and what our
systems have been able to detect but i
do think
those are two separate issues you've
taken down 18 million pieces of
misinformation but how many people have
viewed the misinformation is it more
than 18 million is it less than 18
million that's the number i think people
are talking about you know the white
house said at one point facebook is
killing people that was very bold and
very blunt and very provocative and i
think the president walked that back but
the point he was making i believe is
that people look at it and they act upon
it or they don't act upon it and
facebook is being blamed for that that's
why i'm trying to nail down what is the
number of misinformation that people
have viewed
maybe you don't know it maybe you all
don't know that number
do you see the point i'm making they're
two different numbers here
yeah no i i understand what you're
saying i mean the number that i have off
the top my head that i can share is the
number of pieces of misinformation that
we've taken action against
we also have millions of people have
used our vaccine finder tools to take
their step towards getting the vaccine
and hundreds of millions of of people
have
visited in the u.s and other places have
visited the coronavirus information hub
to get uh um
uh authoritative information about this
yeah it is an ongoing question um
and i
with the technology that we have today
yes it seems like you would know all of
that
the scope of the problem the size of the
audience what draws people's attention
what holds their attention and if you
knew that from a public health point of
view then you could combat it more
effectively well that's what their
business model is based on is developing
that information so i find it hard to
believe he doesn't have it he said and
there's a difference between
misinformation and vaccine hesitancy he
said a lot of this is vaccine hesitancy
it's not misinformation we'll have more
on that tomorrow how they define it is
going to be very fascinating also very
interesting facebook says that since the
start of the pandemic more than 2
billion people have viewed reliable
information about covet and vaccines on
its platform we'll have more of our
exclusive interview with mark zuckerberg
that's tomorrow right here on cbs this
morning including the reason why he sat
down with us he has a special
announcement about the future of
facebook believe me he wasn't saying you
know i'd like to come on and talk about
real information on the platform that is
not why he sat down with us but he he
certainly understands that we have have
to address the news of day and he was
more than willing to do that good on him
for being willing to exactly exactly
right